i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
en 2009 tenía 22 años y era muy feliz
porque aún no era consciente de que al
menos 3 de cada 10 personas en el
planeta no cuentan con acceso a agua
potable
en ese momento estando lejos de casa
estudiando en una universidad muy cerca
de la ciudad de chicago tuve la gran
fortuna de contar con un mentor que me
ayudara a empezar a descubrir lo que
sería mi pasión y ese gran mentor era mi
rumbo de que en algún momento me
convertí en una especie de
guardaespaldas lo seguía como si fuera
su sombra aunque pensándolo bien no es
que en realidad lo necesitara era un
tipo alto de casi dos metros fornido que
pertenece al equipo de fútbol americano
pero bueno les decía que lo seguía casi
como si fuera su sombra porque cada vez
que él iba recorriendo el departamento
yo iba detrás de él apagando cada una de
las luces que él iba dejando encendidas
cerraba las llaves del agua apagaba el
televisor y después de repetirla
incansablemente durante meses que
apagará las luces y cerrar las llaves
cuando no lo requiriera pude darme
cuenta de algo impensable algo que jamás
se hubiera podido imaginar me me estaba
convertido mi papá
al haber salido del estado de shock y
analizar la situación y cada vez que yo
me quedaba dormido y transcurrirá toda
la noche con el televisor encendido
llegaba inmediatamente por la mañana mi
papá diciéndome que a la próxima ocasión
yo iba a tener que pagar la factura de
la electricidad
caí en cuenta de que ese regaño no era
en realidad por la conciencia hacia el
medio ambiente sino que tiene un fondo
económico y es que en general en
latinoamérica reaccionamos mucho más
eficazmente cuando nos afectan el
bolsillo o la cartera y ahora al conocer
cuál es mi inicio de la vida y trabajar
para tratar de erradicar aquellos
comportamientos que hacemos como
personas de forma inconsciente y que
afectan al medio ambiente hay algunos
datos que me ayudan a ilustrar que lo
que ocurre es que en ocasiones podríamos
tal vez no identificar de qué manera
podríamos cuidar a nuestro planeta o
valorar esos recursos que nos ofrece
como el agua que la requerimos para
absolutamente todo lo que hacemos lo que
compramos o lo que comemos según la
organización de las naciones unidas para
la alimentación y la agricultura al
menos el 70 por ciento del agua que
llega hasta a nivel mundial se utiliza
para la producción de alimentos que a
veces ni siquiera consumimos
les pregunto entonces a ustedes que
consideran que gasta una mayor cantidad
de agua la producción de un kilogramo de
carne o la producción de un kilogramo de
pollo para los que pensaron que se trata
de la carne están en lo correcto para
producir tan sólo un kilogramo de este
alimento se requieren hasta 15 mil
litros de agua mientras que para
producir un kilogramo de pollo se
requiere una tercera parte y no es que
sea una pequeña cantidad de tal forma
que nuestras acciones de consumo tienen
un impacto en el uso de este recurso y
si reconocemos el impacto que estamos
generando podríamos ser mucho más
conscientes de optar por otros productos
o disminuir su consumo de estos
alimentos un menor número de veces al
mes en los que esté buscando que se
acuerden de mí regañando los como lo
hacía mi papá cada vez que vayan a comer
una hamburguesa oa cortar un filete pero
si mi intención es que empecemos a
identificar de qué manera podemos
contribuir desde casa o cuál es y en
dónde son las acciones que podríamos
realizar para poder generar un mayor
impacto por ejemplo si pensamos cuál es
el consumo de agua de los diferentes
sectores podríamos pensar que la
industria es la que consume una mayor
cantidad de agua sin embargo en méxico
apenas representa el consumo del 4 por
ciento del agua disponible promedio
anualmente y esto se debe a que el costo
es tan elevado para la industria que se
las tienen que ingeniar y desarrollar
tecnologías para hacer un uso mucho más
eficiente de este recurso así es como
pude verlo cuando trabajaba en una
empresa que se dedicaba a la producción
de papel y cartón aquí desarrollaron la
tecnología suficiente para tratar el
agua del proceso y poderla reinsertar
para disminuir su demanda por una mayor
cantidad de agua potable también puedes
verlo en una empresa dedicada a la
producción de alimentos en donde
capturaban el vapor del agua y lo
compensaban lo reinserta van en el
proceso y de esta manera disminuyen
también la demanda por una mayor
cantidad de agua potable pero entonces
cuál podría ser ese sector que gasta una
mayor cantidad de agua
y tal vez ni siquiera podríamos
imaginarlo pero se trata del sector
agrícola el cual utiliza hasta el 76 por
ciento del agua disponible de mi país de
tal forma que el día de hoy no vamos a
hablar de lo bien que lo hace la
industria ellos en ocasiones ya tienen
este tema más que digerido vamos a
hablar de donde requerimos un mayor
enfoque el problema es que para el año
2030 es decir dentro de 10 años vamos a
necesitar una mayor cantidad de agua
para poder satisfacer las necesidades de
los casi 9.000 millones de habitantes
que se espera que habitamos el planeta
en ese entonces hay algunas estimaciones
que nos indican que para algunos
sectores y para algunos procesos vamos a
requerir hasta un 400 por ciento más de
agua sobre todo por la situación de
pandemia global que estamos viviendo hoy
en día en donde requerimos más y más
agua para poder limpiar y tener las
condiciones de higiene necesarias para
garantizar la salud y la seguridad de
todos y cada uno de nosotros este cambio
de estilo de vida tan abrupto que
estamos viviendo así que el llamado por
el cuidado del agua sea mucho más
urgente
según las estadísticas nacionales en
mexico el día de hoy estamos por debajo
de un nivel de 3 mil 650 metros cúbicos
por habitante por año qué quiere decir
esto jorge well diciéndolo en otras
palabras si hoy en día tenemos la
disponibilidad de dos baldes de agua
para hacer las actividades de higiene y
limpieza en nuestros hogares en 1950
hubiéramos contado con la disponibilidad
de 10 baldes de acuerdo con el instituto
de recursos mundiales cuando alguna
región se encuentra por debajo de los
1000 metros cúbicos por habitante por
año las consecuencias serán tan severas
que comprometerá el desarrollo de
cualquier industria o sector se va a
comprometer la producción de alimentos y
el sistema agrícola y por resultado
también el desarrollo económico de
cualquier país y sabemos que ya hay
muchas regiones en nuestros países que
ya se encuentran por debajo de estos
límites de acuerdo también con un
estudio del agua realizado por el ideam
que depende del ministerio de ambiente y
desarrollo sostenible de colombia al
menos la mitad de la población
colombiana que vive dentro de las zonas
urbanas municipales encontrará un
problema de suministro
toda la presión que se ha metido en el
sistema ya la contaminación de las
fuentes de aguas superficiales como lo
son ríos y lagos otra parte del problema
es que para el año 2050 algunos países
en vías de desarrollo como lo somos
méxico y colombia- va a necesitar la
producción de hasta el 100 por ciento
más de alimentos para abastecer a cada
uno de los habitantes de estos dos
países la demanda de agua que necesitará
el sector agrícola afectaría por
completo la disponibilidad de agua para
realizar cualquier otro tipo de
actividad en nuestros trabajos o
nuestros hogares entonces sí para el uso
agrícola se requiere hasta el 76 por
ciento del agua de un país como méxico
es aquí en donde necesitamos y tenemos
las mayores oportunidades tenemos que
poner colaboraciones globales que nos
ayuden a hacer un uso mucho más
eficiente si somos un país que tiene la
disponibilidad al agua de forma limitada
tanto si somos un país que no tienen
mayor disponibilidad debemos ser
creativos y pensar de qué manera
podríamos desarrollar iniciativas que
pueden ser tan sencillas o complejas
como nuestra propia creatividad nos lo
permita
seguramente pensamos que el aspecto
financiero es una gran barrera y así es
y podríamos reconocer a estos grandes
países que han hecho grandes iniciativas
para poder desarrollar tecnologías para
hacer un uso mucho más eficiente del
agua en el campo pero también tenemos
que identificar estas iniciativas de muy
poca inversión que han generado un gran
impacto para el desarrollo de estas
iniciativas
imaginemos entonces estos grandes
desiertos llenos de cactus y dunas de
arena desiertos como los que tenemos en
chile o en perú aquí llega a llover muy
pocas veces al año y la necesidad por
más agua potable hace que hayan
desarrollado dispositivos que se conocen
como atrapanieblas para capturar el agua
del aire y así poderlo utilizar en los
cultivos también podríamos pensar en los
cultivos en méxico en donde han generado
tiendas artificiales de tierra en los
cultivos para capturar el agua de lluvia
y así poderla dosificar a favor de las
cosechas podríamos también y necesitamos
empezar a identificar que esta
experiencia y conocimiento se requiere
en otros sectores inclusive podríamos
pensar que una colaboración global puede
ser algo muy utópico pero tenemos
excelentes aprendizajes que nos han
ayudado a identificar y a poder cuidar a
nuestro planeta tal como lo fue la
cumbre de montreal en 1987 en donde se
acordó reducir y hasta eliminar la
producción de los refrigerantes
artificiales que estaban dañando a la
capa de ozono
esa iniciativa fue tan exitosa que el
día de hoy vemos que este problema se
haya disminuido considerablemente
vean entonces como si es posible el
hacer una colaboración global a favor de
la conservación del agua este recurso
que necesitamos valorar de cualquier
manera si queremos seguir disfrutando en
paz al lado de una cascada o nadar en un
lago comer frutas y verduras frescas o
algo tan simple como tomar un vaso con
agua necesitamos ponernos en acción
todos juntos necesitamos ponernos en
acción ya muchas gracias
[Música]